covered 19 victims in america has now
exceeded the country's military
casualties in world war
ii the pandemic is the country's worst
crisis for decades but it hasn't stopped
the rich from getting richer
the net worth of american billionaires
has soared by a trillion dollars since
march according to a new report
as tens of millions of americans suffer
from the health
and economic ravages of this pandemic a
few hundred billionaires add to their
massive fortunes
their pandemic profits are so immense
that america's billionaires could pay
for a major covet relief bill
and still not lose a dime of their
pre-virus reaches
the updraft of wealth to the billionaire
class is disturbing at a time when
millions face eviction
destitution and loss billionaires are
extracting wealth at a time when
essential workers
are pushed into the viral line of fire
the campaign group americans for tax
fairness looked at the net worth of the
country's 651 billionaires
it found their extra wealth gained
during the pandemic would be enough to
dish out three thousand dollars to every
single american
alternatively one trillion could close
the budget deficit of all state and
local governments twice over
it's roughly equal to the entire amount
spent by the federal government on
health care in 2019
and nearly four times more than the
stimulus payments made earlier in the
year
to 159 million americans our guests
debated the issues
this is a capitalism on government life
support
and the side effect of that is to make
those who own
shares the overwhelming bulk being owned
by the richest people
even richer and while everybody else is
in trouble
the way that they blame uh uh capitalism
for destroying uh uh
the the poor and uh and and creating
great inequality these government
policies did exactly that
we have lockdowns crushing small and
medium businesses we have state home
orders
which drove people into an unemployed
and largely virtual existence
we had a wave of monetary policy which
drove up prices and financial markets
i always love these kinds of analyses as
if the government is a deus ex machina
that drops from the government
there's nothing naive here the
government isn't doing
something that has a result the
government is itself the result
of the way this society works which puts
enormous wealth and therefore political
power
in the hands of a very small number of
people who turn
out to have a government policy that
makes them richer
this burst of new wealth is just is
purely a product of of government policy
um it wasn't necessary you know the
unintended consequences
of the lockdowns and such and in this
case they call them non-pharmaceutical
interventions but there's also capacity
limits on businesses
are going to be the almost the opposite
of what we're hoped for the draconian
policies they've increased the gap
uh between the rich and poor they've
created new concentrations of wealth
there's tremendous consolidation going
on right now
let me be clear here we could have been
prepared for this virus the way other
countries were
we could have handled it better the way
other countries have
it's a pathetic sad story of a system
spinning out of control so that it's
unjust
inequality keeps getting worse we have a
monopoly in this country we've had it
for a century
we have two parties we don't allow two
businesses to dominate most of our
industries
but we allow these two parties to
dominate our politics
that's very convenient for the computer
the class of corporate
directors who donate the bulk of the
money to both of them
who pulled the strings for both of the
parties you can't really have a monopoly
without government help because
innovation never stops you have
you you what you need to have a monopoly
as richard said is you need government
controls you need
artificial controls like patents unlike
copyrights and all that sort of thing
healthcare is a perfect example of that
it's a business it's it's
it's a sector which is super regulated
um and
therefore you have entrenched interest
there and for that reason we shouldn't
be surprised
that those costs are rising and rising
and rising and uh
you know to to to to to to with no end
in sight i mean
i think that is uh
what one of the one of us may be maybe
the picture perfect examples of what
happens when government gets up to its
neck in an industry
to think of this as a government policy
is strange
the beneficiary here are corporations
they
operate with four industries doctors
hospitals device and drug makers
and the insurers they've got us by the
throat
we have to pay those prices that they
control
yes peter's right they use the
government to cement their monopoly
as monopolists always have but the
impetus the desire
the need to control the market to
squeeze more profits
that's what drives the government to do
what they do
in support of these interests trying to
maximize the money they can squeeze
out of our health care if you look at
these lockdowns how many people
i mean if you think of people locked at
home people with nothing to do
stores being closed what was keeping
people alive what was keeping people fed
what was keeping people's minds
sane right facebook google amazon
netflix things like that
those those service providers and
there's many other businesses too many
of these bit large corporations are
offering
uh people some some sort of refuge from
these heavy-handed
government policies which never had to
be so heavy-handed
i think i think the idea that we would
ask billionaires to do more
um to take to pay back in like that is
just
again it should be a punchline but it's
actually a policy proposal
well i could not disagree more so maybe
we can end on that
none of these people are almost none of
them they're a couple of exceptions
have come forward to say say like
jeffrey bezos
i have 200 billion dollars if i give
away half of it to help my fellow
citizens
i'll still be the richest person in this
country but it'll be a hundred billion
dollars more
to help out my fellow citizens the
harshness of america
is that they don't even think about that
and that's a sign of a society
falling apart
you